yo welcome to podcast Ville the church I
was hap of what's Happening Now is
brought to you by number one ZIP
recruiter are you hiring do you know
where to post a job to find the best
candidates you know how hard it is to
find great talent out there and how
important it is for your business to get
somebody who's reliable good smart
that's why we have a zip recruiter find
out today why ZipRecruiter has been used
by businesses of all sizes to find the
most qualified job candidates with
immediate results and right now my
listeners can post jobs on ZipRecruiter
for free that's right free just go to
ziprecruiter.com church
number two listen to me and listen to me
good when I go to the airport in all
these little places
I go with Lyft why because Lyft knows
that their drivers are will keep them
moving so they do everything they can to
make sure their drivers are happy on
every single trip
join the ride sharing company that
believes in treating its people better
go to lyft.com Joey today and you'll get
a 500 new driver bonus that's lyft.com
Joey today limited time only terms apply
kick that [__] meal Lee
the Church of What's Happening Now here
you go
old school I was telling Lee this song
is [__] 40 years old
kick it Lee I need this [__] speakers
to blow my ears what's with this [__]
fat volume
give it to me [__]
oh [__]
yeah
three little hot black chicks in the
background that's all they say give me
love give me all that you got are you
[__] nuts the Church of what's
happening now here we go
foreign
Give Me Love [__] how you doing
your host Joey Diaz my main man and the
co-host chair the one and only the
ultimate the flying Jew of death Mr Lee
Syed we learned something very important
today Joey well we learned something
this week remember to put a guest down
here that can't handle an edible because
now we're put in a bad position I didn't
book all the guests a lot of people out
of town but we don't give a [__] people
this is one of those podcasts with a
chit chat about a few things that have
been on my mind lately uh
then that's basically it I gotta go to
St Louis on Thursday
I'll be at the [__] uh helium over
there I haven't been to St Louis in two
years so I'm excited man what do you get
what do you do in St Louis like what is
there barbecue in St Louis I have no
[__] idea I'm going to write jokes
lift some weights and do five [__]
shows and I'm back on a goddamn plane I
keep it nice and easy I do the same [__]
and everything you know me dog nice and
easy no drama my uh my agent Gordon
Warnock
he's a great [__] guy I've been uh
talking to him for three years we still
have made a dollar together
and uh you know he's been trying to talk
me to write a book for the last three
years and I started
[__] six times and because of my
writing insecurities and the whole thing
you know it's it's taken years and I in
a way I wanted it this way I really
wanted to think this out
and make notes instead of just rushing
it like a [__] uh and give you guys
the wrong facts and whatnot but the
bottom line is uh last month I was doing
really well on this page lit lift what I
basically did was an idea A friend gave
me that he said just write a sentence
every day start with that that's what I
did every day I would go back write a
sentence then I got to the point where I
couldn't wait to go to it and I would
write a few sentences a day and clean up
and I'd put together about two and a
half chapters in the last day last month
one day I go to just right in there and
the website is down and this one on
three or four days
and my wife you know she's a [__]
private investigator she went online and
went to [__] Chit Chat [__] rooms
and everybody was pissed that Lit lift
went out of business something happened
live with it but it took my book so now
I gotta start from scratch so to put
myself in a position where I had to do
this I'm hiring somebody from the month
of eight August
pretty basically I only have San
Francisco and Ontario in the month of
August so that's one week I have to be
on the plane
and for three week and a half weeks we
just want to write this [__] uh the
three or four chapters to get an advance
and to see what we have to do you know
and it's a good learning experience for
both of us he's from NYU
but the bottom line was that throughout
this whole three years the thing that's
driven me not to even send them this
stuff is fear
you know I'm sick and tired of dealing
with fear and I dealt with it
for [__] 30 years and then I started
doing little things about it just little
little things but anyway to get back to
this book Gordon sent me a book I always
get little emails from people and
they send it to the web page and you
know what man I know a lot of you guys
are aspiring writers we just talk with
writers this week
but this applies for everything you know
he sent me a book called The Art of War
for writers
okay and I've read half of it already
but there was something I read
in the inter-fuck induction
that I had to write down on a piece of
paper because it [__] up me so much
and let me tell you what this is
you know he breaks the book into
chapters so the audit war is for writers
my modest attempt as a field manual for
all writing wretches because I know how
hard it is out there
following Sun Tzu's example I'll keep
the subject compact sub soon under three
main areas reconnaissance he wrote this
uh the section is primarily but the
mental game of writing because what
happens in your head affects everything
else Dick Simon of Simon and Schuster
Fame once said all writers
without exception are scared to death
some simply hide it better than others
That's The Story of My Life
I've just hidden my fears and I've
gotten away with it and I know a lot of
you guys
uh whenever we talk about the subject
fear I get a lot of emails three four
days later that now
they understood what was going on with
them and we haven't touched on in a
while I told Lee I go you know what man
I've been getting more and more emails
from writers and you know we haven't
spoken about fear lately because this
that little statement that a Publishing
Company a guy
uh Simon Schuster whatever the [__] they
all would say you know all exception
without exemption have some type of fear
what do you think
is there a difference between fear and
doubt like doubting yourself
they're cousins yeah it's [__] up
they're [__] cousins and they and
they come at you from two directions you
follow me yeah it's different so once
fear is bad enough but then once he
calls his cousin doubt into the [__]
picture that's when you really have a
problem and that's what everything
that's to do anything that's when I
first started stand up that's when I
went to Alberto crane school and drove
out to the front and drove home the
first two times that's just fear that's
just something that you know and it's
like it goes back to what we were
talking about a few months ago this
could ruin your life yeah it could ruin
your [__] life and I let it ruin my
life in many aspects but I don't give a
[__] my life is ruined in those aspects
you know what I'm saying like I'm the
type of guy that I won't go for a four
o'clock audition on the west side
because I'm scared of traffic I've done
that traffic and I gotta tell you
something that ain't that [__] bad
it's worse in my head right I always
call you and go I'm in the [__] car
doing 90 I'm the 405 and also I'm like
I'm not gonna get home till seven also
I'm pulling up at 5 30. I'm going how
the [__] did that happen
it's worse in my head and that's what we
let fear do
something that it gets worse in your
head
and then while you're doing it you're
like this wasn't so [__] bad what was
all that [__] about
what was all that [__] about it's
like when I go get a needle for years it
was just [__] three days of drama
following for a 10 second needle
that's what all this fear was into yeah
you know sometimes when we have fear we
it stops us from growing
it stopped me for [__] 40 years stop
me
I was scared to know if I could do it or
not
and that's a horrible thing to live with
whether I could do something or not sure
I could do it but guess what if I can't
I'm going to give it an all New York try
and I go back to this topic and I know
you people like Joey we don't want to
hear this I go back to Jujitsu when this
fear I had a Jiu-Jitsu being on my back
what I did there was like uh two months
ago in May I think there was a week
after going to Alberto cranes for a year
and a half
that I didn't go because of fear
really yeah because I was jumping rope
or something I didn't feel good and I'm
like I can't breathe I'm not gonna go
I didn't go all [__] week one time
after going there free that's how much
fear affects my [__] life
you know with The Comedy Store I'm not
scared to go to The Comedy Store I just
like to keep it to a minimum because I
lived there at one point I don't want it
to get like that again but you still get
a little I don't know what the word
would be but you still get anxious or
whatever excited for your stand up sure
sure absolutely but with like Jiu Jitsu
for the longest time I had this fear so
what did I do last month I got a Groupon
I heard about this teacher I heard about
this school
and before I joined Albertos I had heard
about this guy and I heard about how
clean this school was how he ran in
school
there's no timer in the school for
competitions he doesn't really like
competitive he believes in Old School
Jiu-Jitsu the basics
and that's it
so hold on Groupon you know me I found
the Groupon
29 bucks for the first month and I went
down there just to try it out
in the last month because of that week I
punished myself
I forced myself to go to Jujitsu as much
as I could and I went 14 times last
month what do you normally go eight oh
Jesus okay I went 14 times last month
this time so far this month I'm at six
and it's only the tenth and I got all
one next week off so I could go four
times I found a new way to train I go to
Alberto's and I go to the other place
the other place is a little slow it's a
lot more drilling there's only 10
minutes of sparring at the end
but they work on a lot more technique I
go there now I because of that week I
missed in the fear I punished myself
I punished myself that's the type of
dude I am I punish myself
I forced myself to go to eliminate the
fear eliminate the fear eliminate this
fear after a year and a half I'm still
[__] scared
and it was like acupuncture for the
first two years I went but I was
petrified
the whole drive up there on a Tuesday
I'd be [__] petrified and I'd forget
that I had to go and I eat an edible
and that would really send me into
[__] Mars once I went up there
so
do you think with like the Jujitsu
aspect of it were you trying to find
almost like the like the root of your
like bassist fear yes because you could
have gone and like gone to a writing
class but like you were like okay I
really don't like being on my back that
will didn't even think it would help
everything else I would I thought it
would help me in every other aspect of
my life just to eliminate that little
little fear that I had we'll lighten my
aspect a little bit it would give me
more illumination and all the other
aspects of my life my relationship
my friendships
what I do for a career
or how I am as a parent
does it just give you confidence like
overcoming a fear is it like absolutely
yeah
listen fear is not being prepared
once you feel prepared you won't have
any more fear
it's so weird you think that's a little
more fear all right let me tell you
something
I gotta I really don't like auditioning
the last four or five years okay
I really don't like it no more you know
why
I can't see
I can't see it guys
that reason yeah I can see but what that
means when you go into an audition you
gotta either have glasses on
or know the lines by heart
I mean backwards and from which isn't
always possible
which isn't always possible
but in after I've lost so many roles
from not mowing the lines and going in
there with glasses
that I don't really like auditioning
anymore okay it's not my strong fit
anymore because at some point I gotta
look the glasses I always bring the
paper in to keep me focused okay
so I always keep it right in front of me
to keep me focused so if I do get in
trouble I could take a look on the slide
the last couple months I haven't really
been I got an audition two weeks ago
it was for this TV show
I put it on tape around the corner when
they tell you to put a when you have an
audition you go to the studio you sign
your name
you go in there's a casting director an
assistant in the room sometimes a
director you go in you read if they want
to call back now that means you're going
in for the second time or the third time
the more times you go in the more people
are in that room
so the second time you might go into the
director and they might like you now the
third time you have to go in for the
producers
the director will be in the room in the
old days late like okay we'll use The
Sopranos for example okay
when I went in for The Sopranos I went
in for the initial audition bam did well
in it once I went in the room with the
15 people I fell apart
this is also 19. this is also 2000.
I wasn't young as a human being but I
was young as an actor I didn't really
have all my acting jobs then
I was okay I could book stuff I had book
Spider-Man 2 I had booked uh
a bunch of different jobs at that point
but this was when I walked into that
silver cup studios in New York
and I saw all these people in the room
David Chase and all these [__]
in the room my hands started trembling
with the sides in my hand
and I could have probably got that role
but because they saw that fear what are
they going to do when they put cameras
on
it's a two hundred thousand dollar day
and I'm doing that for [__] an hour
trembling or not remembering my lines
that's I was a great character that was
great but I didn't I wasn't confident
and that confidence gave me fear and
that fear didn't get me the role in the
audition so going back to what you just
said what about that audition were you
not prepared for was it just that you
had just started acting what do you mean
you said uh fear means you're not you
don't feel prepared right you're not
prepared so that's why you have a little
fear if you have confidence you walk in
there like you have the biggest dick in
my room so what during the what made you
feel like you weren't prepared for the
surprise at that time it wasn't that I
wasn't prepared it was a little bit of
on preparation
uh I was still living in doubt about who
the [__] I was these people if they find
out I went to prison they're not going
to like me right you know then I think
I'm a [__] like a kidnapper or
whatever there's some people look at
life like that and there's nothing you
could do
I just had all these little fears that
all built up into one and when I went in
that room I couldn't cover the spread
that's it and I'm man enough to admit it
but after that I didn't really shaken
auditions no more even when I met with
to analyze that by the time I wanted to
analyze that my fears had been tackled
that what happened in that soprano room
was not gonna happen again
so for years I wanted for all these
roles whether I had them or not but it's
like I told my agent the other day my
job since I moved to this town is not
the book to roll is to disrupt the
auditioning process
okay what I mean by that is we were
thinking about lisaat for this and if he
didn't work out for this we were
thinking of Alberto crane
but Tim [__] chubby kid from Jersey
came and Joey Diaz and knocked all our
thoughts [__] aloof
because now and 9 out of ten I wouldn't
even get the [__] roll but it didn't
matter I had [__] up the casting
process because when you write a role
you already have somebody in mind for
that role as you're writing it you see
somebody
and then when you go on the casting
thing in the casting world you have to
see threesome bodies
just in case so now you're like okay
he's coming in he's coming depending on
the read but now they see a fat little
comedian that's coming in for a drama
show
and he's right there with the two guys
that was always what I was going for the
disruptive process so they could put my
head shot up and go what are we gonna do
with this fat [__]
what the [__] I'm gonna do with this fat
[__] and I got really good at that for a
while so what'd they give you I mean I
know you've said it a couple times
sometimes I got the wrong sometimes I
did but when they give you like you just
said would they give you a different
role maybe sometimes sometimes smaller
but now you're in mind okay you're in
mind while they're shooting you're in
their mind you created a DOT with them
did we do the right move but now I
enjoyed this oh that's a disruption
That's A disruption you know you gave it
everything you got you went into three
reads you were right there with
everybody else but there's different
things to acting maybe you didn't have
enough Twitter followers which is very
important today yeah oh my that's crazy
you didn't have uh an agency that fought
for you maybe you didn't have a manager
that fought for you and call them up and
let them know who you're with and what
do you do and you know there's so many
variables
so I'm not I'm never mad about those
auditions the whole moral of this is
fear now sadly when I was in Vegas
I you know I woke up and I went for
breakfast and I won't smoke a joint and
then I went for a little walk and I came
upstairs and I don't even know it was a
thousand [__] degrees
when I go upstairs like I gotta show at
7 30. you know what man I'm gonna work
out before I work out I'm gonna take a
[__] nap
and I tried the nap but I could I was
charging the phone like in the living
room and I can hear the phone buzzing uh
and I heard it like four times in a row
like who the [__] is trying to get a
hold of me and it was my agent on this
Saturday
I'm like what the [__] does he want he
was like I'm a y or something
he goes hey man you're going into Reed
tomorrow
they want to hear they want you to
record go for a call back he goes do you
really want to go in front of a Sunday
and I go [__] yeah
for that thing I read that TV show
so I was thinking about how how I would
have reacted 10 years ago maybe 15 years
ago today
I looked at the sheet and the director
was Ben Stiller and that's what I was
meeting with oh [__] so I was like [__]
I gotta go meet with Ben Stiller now let
me tell you something you have no idea
how that could work
what do you mean in what aspect you
might go in there and he's a nice guy so
he he relaxes you as a director you
don't get caught up because it's Ben
Stiller
and you lay the read down you might also
go in there he might be a dick you might
get caught up with it
and the fam
you know that's what I used to do 15
years ago yeah even before when you just
go through every scenario when I put my
when I broke the audition down it was
two scenes but the thing I put in the
top was Ben Stiller of the page
because I didn't want it to be a shock
when I walked in the room
and it really wasn't a shot when I
walked in he was sitting there reading
some [__] paper with some chicken two
bicycles in the room
he goes I'll be right with you he came
out he shook my hand the other dudes and
he went in and then some chick came out
and brought me in there and when I
walked in I could feel the anxiety level
getting ready to rise but I wouldn't let
it
I was like this ain't [__]
I'm just going to read for this guy that
fear was ready to start coming up and I
just put it in this [__] place but I
put it in this place because of the
confidence
I didn't put it in this place because
I'm a [__] tough guy I put the fear
in its place because I was confident
when I went in there from the time I got
off that plane I read those sides I
printed those sides in Vegas and I
[__] yellowed them out and everything
so Saturday night I went back after the
comedy show and I read those things for
an hour over and over and over and over
I read them without my glasses over and
over and over and over on the plane over
and over and over and over I got home I
took a nap I got up and I just focused
on that
so when I walked in the room I knew
those lines backwards and frontwards
with or without glasses oh [__] okay and
there was one scene where I even wore
glasses just to prove my point like if
you're in this situation and you're an
old time
guy nine out of ten you got glasses so I
even put the glasses on in that scene he
was like that was pretty good in the
audition oh cool so in the audition I
read it with glasses one time and
without glasses just to let them know I
knew the lines what do you
how did you put like the feeling like
when you said you put the fear in its
place do you have like a a thought that
you go through do you do anything or is
it just like a reaction now
it's a reaction it's breathing it's a
little bit of breathing okay breathing
through your nose real quick
keeping your shoulders up
basically it was the mental part of it I
knew the material gotcha and I didn't
let
him throw me off
you know I told the story on here once
that when I got Grudge Match
I went on the set and it was the first
time LL Cool J
was working with Dinero
and the first two or three scenes the
scenes were nothing they had to get cut
because LL Cool J got caught up with
dinero uh you look at that arrow and
you're looking at his eyes and you're
seeing Al Capone you've seen Henry Hill
you're seeing uh whatever Jimmy Burke
you're seeing [__] Deer Hunter you've
seen Godfather Two it's really weird and
all those images go to your head and
just shut you the [__] out because I did
the first time you see someone like
really big yeah and especially if you
have to do lines with them
like you have to do scenes with them in
a movie or something the first scene's
always a throwaway
because you get caught up even
Spider-Man too with that dude when I saw
him all I kept thinking about was Boogie
Nights doc [__] right all I kept
thinking about was Boogie Nights I mean
that Chinese dude
and I could feel it overpowering me in
the first two takes I couldn't even say
a [__] word they might not even have
the time
but like you know how we how you do like
the pre-church Periscope with the guests
and you talk with the guests they calm
them down I'm surprised after 50 years
or six however many years of making
hundreds of movies directors don't do
that for like their star actors and just
have like a get-together with everyone
they're gonna have to talk with
they do okay for a couple minutes they
give you three minutes yeah three
minutes and they tell you what they
expect from you for this film and blah
blah blah
but
if they did what I do
take them you know
when I do that to people that whole
thing listen you're my brother
I don't ever want you to do anything for
me but we're on the road I don't say get
me water or get me Italian my brother I
get it myself
there's one thing I do ask you to do for
me and that's always go get the guest
all that is psychological
I go get the guests myself
I do all that as a psychological way
because you slow them down
oh okay
I I didn't know that yeah you slow them
down
so when I if I was to walk out there
they'd start with the [__] suckers and
you slow them that
um they talk to you and it's pretty
funny
the last couple times without even
people thinking I've seen I've tell I've
noticed you tell people sit down
sit right there it's funny that's the
whole system
that's part of the whole breakdown to
slow them down
oh okay okay I didn't know it was so
thought out no I could go out there and
get you right I don't I make them slow
you down they're thinking they're gonna
see me they see you slows them down you
walk up the stairs you come into the
back here
you always tell them have a seat we give
them a water a taller process
whatever they were thinking they're not
thinking it no more oh
okay it's like when
it's like me and you would get into an
argument okay
about numbers or or drug deal that
you're not supposed to be doing and I go
to castellano's house not Castellano the
other guy the gambino okay Gambino had a
wife that looked like a grandma
so he would always make her answer the
door because how no matter how mad I was
she'd take the air out of yourselves
and then she'd ask you in and sit you on
the couch and offer you coffee you never
saw a caller
you never saw Carlo until she told you
to go into his office oh that was done
for a reason
Carlo Gambino did that for a reason he
made her answer the door for a reason to
slow people down
sit him down or from coffee
and whatever they're in a rush to tell
you what's up Lee what's on your mind
that [__] [__] sucking Jew stole my
[__] you're not gonna say that no
she just took all the energy out of here
it's amazing how much stock gets put
into this and like it doesn't
like for me I'm just like oh yeah
someone answered the door it's all a
game it's like when you go get
a [__] condominium one of those time
travels [__]
they have a different teams of people
talking to you that's to confuse the
buyer
you know when you go buy a car like when
you went to a regular place like Boulder
Toyota you dealt with one salesman
a finance guy when you go to a place
like Douglas Toyota in the old days you
dealt with six [__] and nobody
took responsibility for nothing
okay interested anything to get to the
sale anything and when you come back and
say well Lisa I get new tires we don't
even working no more
you know it's it's it's all
you know in the old days
if you went to the dentist okay the
dentist did an x-ray looked at your
teeth
told you what you needed
and then
he [__] talked to you and told you
how much it was gonna cost you
no more go to the dentist now you're an
x-ray he looks at your teeth he walks
out some little Filipina chick comes in
with a [__] piece of paper sits down
next to him says okay this is what needs
to be done
we need this this this this you gotta
come and come up with a thousand dollars
the dentist could tell you that why do
you think she tells you that
so you don't get mad at the dentist I
guess it's just a bunch of reasons but
oh that just started about 15 years ago
the dentist was never like that
they took a page of a salesmanship
that's creepy I never experienced that
until I moved out here yeah out here
it's very good they took me out of the
chair they took you out of the chair sit
you down and the dentist is nowhere to
be found and some [__] chick talks to
you like that those are all sales taxes
I hated that it's [__] crazy it's
crazy until you see them
you don't when you find out the real
heart of sales now you understand ninety
percent of the world and how it works
you understand when you see a a uh a
trailer for a film right and you see
what they're trying to sell you and how
they're trying to sell it to you when
you see a commercial whenever you see
things you see when you see a fight
through the UFC
like what happened today you see how
they're going to sell it to you only
idiots are falling for this [__]
thing really yeah it's gonna be 99 to
get in high definition pay-per-view I
thought it'd be more if you support this
you're a [__] [__] I don't want to
see the press conferences I don't want
to see nothing
no not even a little bit another thing
nothing there is no part of this
sales joke that I'm getting from these
people
there is nothing that impresses me from
this and I see it coming down the pipe
I'm working that weekend it doesn't
[__] matter to me I'm not cancer and
people have asked me if I could host a
party not at all
and I guess because if you don't if you
watch any part of it then you're buying
into it so you kind of you kind of have
to just say no just say no
I kind of want to see who wins though
you'll find that in an hour that's true
and you'll save a hundred bucks and you
won't be part of the [__] general
population
which is the most important thing
why why is that so important
that Gap
it's so funny when I used to work for
Curtis Sloat part of his pitch was
you know Curtis
in those days got his information when I
worked for a sports service Curtis got
his information
you know from different people and he
had different Scouts and whatnot but one
of the biggest points of information
was what we give them at four o'clock
we'd give them our call sheets
and he'd look at what every soccer
bought into
and then you learn how people buy into
stuff and why they buy into it
the end of the Colorado Sports advisor's
speech in those days
when I worked there was okay Lee you
don't want to [__] work with me don't
work on me who you betting tonight [__]
and you go I got the [__] Knicks and
I got the Nets
the smart thing is for me to call you up
and go hey no no not even call you I'm
gonna have you there I'll go listen one
of your moves is opposite mine and I'm
definitely coming in I got a five star
we'll talk tomorrow and I'll hang up
my moves weren't opposite yours I don't
even know what you know what I'm saying
and one of them is going to lose hope
creating a doubt sure if you're like the
general population you're gonna lose one
of them yeah at least both of them oh
God
so that's what I'm saying to you the GP
always loses why would you want to be a
part of that
that's how they make their money
by the thought of the GP and what they
think
you know you bet New England for the
Super Bowl over Atlanta not because
you're a [__] genius but because
you're a family and a fan okay you
didn't bet them because you looked the
stats and all this [__] and you said
Atlanta's going to defend them
you know you bet them because you're a
fan
the people who bet
Atlanta for the fuzz it's the the sizzle
they always tell your marketing to sell
the sizzle not the steak
so does that mean like the most listen
exciting aspect what's the special
tonight Joey
I got a nice 12 ounce New York cut I
make with mashed potatoes fresh mashed
potatoes with butter
and I'll give you a house salad for
15.95
gone okay what if I said let me tell you
something Lee I got these steaks that
just came in from Omaha the [__] cow
was an Olympic runner okay
okay number two I just had one of those
steaks Lee and when I came off the
[__] thing with some mushrooms and
some onions you could smell the
seasonings and the [__] meat that
meat with some mashed potatoes home
whipped with butter and I put a little
red onion in there to really Sizzle it I
got these Tomatoes I got do you
understand the salesmanship of that
right yeah I'm building value and
everything along the way
okay you know when you get in a car with
a good costume they'll even sell you the
rear view mirror look at that rear view
mirror look at that it's sturdy you ever
push your mirror and it falls off yeah
yeah this is sturdy feel this I can
[__] put a gorilla on that
you know what I'm saying we give you a
mirror we don't charge you 15. it's a 50
mirror but that mirror is never going to
break you sell that look at that ashtray
look at that [__] ashtray it's
beautiful
you could fit 2 000 pennies in there or
55 joints that put value on everything
okay gotcha that's a Salesman along the
way
so what do you like how do you take that
and put that into your writing or or
you're acting like do you take those
lessons that you learn
always like if I'm talking to a
potential sponsor or
something I always dope it up a little
bit it's not like me sending you an
email like some dope to another dope
you gotta dope it up a couple different
type of words in there
when we you know we talked yesterday no
when we spoke yesterday briefly
you know those type of words give them a
different
for the type of person that you are even
though I'm a [__] puke and uh I got
felonies and all that [__] it just makes
them feel you know all those little
words
not when you describe it I went to this
restaurant it was amazing no no no no
I'm talking about from the sales aspect
of it right you always say like the ten
thousand ten thousand dollar project
with a ten dollar presentation yeah how
are you gonna sell a ten thousand dollar
project with a pet ten dollar shoes
right okay I'm fine
it's uh
because the doubt thing is is my is the
toughest part for me I think I don't
think for me and we the the other book
The War of art talks about uh getting in
your own way interference when there's
resistance resistance and there's doubt
yeah and they're cousins too oh that's
the worst one I think that's the worst
one mixer resistance I mean everybody
who listens to this podcast I saved 50
of people struggling to find who the
[__] they are and part of the reason why
they never found out who they are is
because they don't let themselves find
out who they are
that doubt that they'll find out the
truth same [__] I did for 30 years when
I was snorting coke
I didn't want to know what I could
become I didn't want to know even though
the [__] reports and the prison and
so I could do some in my life I didn't
want it I was scared shitless what if I
do do something with my life then what
I had to give up my little party and I
finally gave him a little party
and now I can look at myself in the
mirror and I got a little bit more
confidence and you know it all goes hand
in hand
it all goes hand in hand Lee so doubt
resistance you know it's levels
it goes from doubt to should I do this
no I'm not gonna [__] write it right
anyway to it goes from resistance to
doubt I'm sorry we were talking and it's
a overused Talkback on all podcast now
like the how people are mean online and
the thing that got me over it and the
thing that that is really the worst part
about doubt for me is I'm meaner to
myself in my head than anyone could ever
be me over email me too like it's it's
like it's terrible me too and I've been
mean you know when I have doubt
I look at the doubt I look at the reason
and if the reasons good enough I let
doubt win
but so many times doubt has been so
[__] wrong in my life
that I don't let it affect me no more
does he look like looking back and even
now like if someone asks you for advice
or me for advice I can see them looking
at things the wrong way like their
brains just getting ahead of them
I have a I have an issue with myself I
don't I don't think I see see that in
myself I'm like Oh my brain it just goes
and I let it go and I don't see I don't
I can't see it from the outsider's
perspective
and which way and oh well no that
person's not mad at you or this idea is
fine or or you're doing good there or
like whatever it may be
how everyone talks themselves into like
hating themselves or thinking that the
whatever whatever it is
when you can see that in other people I
can't see that I can't talk myself out
of it I can't look at the reasons be
like oh no doubts being stupid there
you've put in the work and or you did
this and that I just always assume the
worst
the mental decision is the toughest
decision to make
because that's the one that's going to
control everything okay I don't know
what switch I hit when I stopped doing
blow
the mental condition once you don't
allow it
whether I stop smoking cigarettes or
stop doing blow or stop drinking diet
soda or everything I let go of through
the years
doubt always said it's not going to work
out for you right yeah you know that you
think of your life without [__] Diet
Coke come on how you gonna eat a [__]
hamburger you know when it was
cigarettes how are you gonna smoke a
joint not Chase it with a cigarette when
it was cocaine is how you gonna have a
good time
you know it was all these things in my
life that brought up to that you know
doubt always is lost in my world today I
have doubts all the time
and the more the doubt the more I have
to do it
the stronger the doubt
the more I have to do it you push
yourself to do it push yourself to do it
because that means if you push that
doubt something good is going to happen
you think so I know so I know so for a
fact
I know so for a fact
you have to think about things like when
you go
with anything it's doing it the smart
way
and to learn to do something the smart
way you have to do it the wrong way for
a while
and that's what people never realize
that to do something the right way you
have to do it the wrong way for a while
and then one day
if you're [__] it might take six
months it might take six days it might
take six years you as a human being like
myself would say this isn't working
this isn't working it doesn't take a
genius to know
that this isn't working right I'm happy
I caught this in the sixth day you know
and let's use it for I could use it for
a common example I could use it for the
podcast we started in the morning for a
while and then it just wasn't working it
wasn't working for my health right it
was four or five days a week I had to
get up at five four and go to bed two it
just wasn't working so
we made a constant decision when uh
for a year
14 months I went to Alberto Grand jiu
jitsu and I went with the writing
tensions
but I went for the wrong reasons
I was doing stuff that was wrong
why were you going I was going just to
breathe and by breathing and laying on
somebody I wasn't doing anything for
myself
I got involved I started doing the the
drill classes I started doing the tech
tact fit classes and I thought about
something
I thought it was just like comedy and it
was like No Good Deed done goes on
whatever punish yeah you know when you
do something good for yourself
something Good's always going to come
from me well it's now or in six years
you're gonna see something
I read something and it said I was
training dumb
I read something online and as I was
reading like I'm doing it wrong
I'm [__] up
and I switched it around and it worked
out
you know and let's let's talk about the
workout okay because I added stretching
I added ice bags
I added uh CBD oil to my training I had
a lot of stretching to my training and I
added like today I rolled twice I could
have rolled three times I wrote twice I
took a breather in between because that
one roll my it's the law diminishing
returns I want to come back tomorrow
right okay so now instead of working on
three days a week doing Jiu Jitsu and
struggling being sore walking around aha
I go four times
like nothing happened
I did the same routine I come home I put
a nice back on my back while I'm writing
down the moves I learned the ice back is
on there 20 25 minutes
I go through my computer my notes will
email me who I I send you stuff print
this for me brother
I put that down I eat I take a shower I
rush I wash all that [__] off me that I
eat
it's a process then that bag is freezing
now I go do two or three more errands I
come back at four and I put ice packs on
my knees both of those
so now the next day I'm more refreshed I
started doing a little more
and cutting back a little on some areas
and now I get to get more pleasure out
of it and I get to improve more because
I'm going more
very interesting I've been sitting there
and going and rolling four times and
four gorillas and then going home and
while I'm eating my [__] body shaking
[__] no that don't happen no more now I
go
Bing I'm ready to go because I have a
different effect to it that's what
happens after a while it took me 14
months I'm sorry I'm not a [__]
working out Guru
I don't know about this stuff but I read
you have to [__] read
you're very in some ways you can be very
set in your ways anyone can
but I was thinking like I was about to
say that but thinking about it you do
try a lot of stuff you have to because
for years I wouldn't try a lot of things
and I would go on no because they're
self stupidity
or self whatever I wouldn't try anything
wouldn't try anything
and now it's not a day go by that I
don't try something
I'm 54. I threw half of my life away
I do this podcast
for various reasons but one of them is
for young listeners not to do the same
mistakes I did
yeah I go to yoga yeah I'll go to a
[__] ballet class if it means I'll
recover more and I'll get something out
of it you have to try [__] right well
and obviously you don't want people to
go like to be a criminal or like to do
that but you like you just said
you don't know how to do something the
right way until you've done it the wrong
way yes so don't people need to make
some of these mistakes absolutely okay
absolutely you have to make some of
these mistakes
but you can avoid some of them also
you could avoid some of them by thinking
it out
a lot of mistakes I did I let addiction
push it a lot of mistakes I did I let uh
my insecurities pushing not a lot of
this the people I listen to the podcast
have the same things that I had going on
no and very few people and I don't have
the same things they were going on we
all come from different backgrounds and
different walks of life
but fear doubt
exactly all that [__] hits us the same
whether you're black white black you got
two good parents you got one missing
parent
whatever we all have those same [__]
little insecurities
you know today I went to a cranes
and he's having an in-house competition
this week
and after the last two months I made a
commitment to go to Kansas City
but if this wasn't if this was a couple
years ago I would have canceled Kansas
City really and none of that in-house
competition on a Saturday
and
I'll tell you why because I don't want
to compete at all but this would be a
fear
and like I told today there's a kid that
really takes care of me in Jiu Jitsu
he's a really good kid okay he's a very
good Jujitsu player very good he works
hard
he's there five days a week he lifts
weights
dedicated but he suffers from kind of
the same should I suffer from social
anxiety
when you wrestle with somebody part of
it isn't the breathing it's the anxiety
that you're gonna get died I don't know
but you're gonna get beat up or
something we both share those same
things so when we roll together I could
see that he's looking at my eyes to see
if I get an anxiety attack or whatever
he cares you know and so that pulled him
aside like are you doing the competition
on Saturday because now I don't think so
I go listen man you're here with family
even if you have an anxiety attack
you're here with family
nothing bad could happen to you it's
like you're in Orange County and having
anxiety attack in front of 400 people
here it's your family
the reason why I go to Alberta family if
I get an anxiety attack and fall
backwards I know Alberto's gonna take
good care of me
you know what I'm saying people aren't
going to be scared they know what your
ailments are they know they watch you
breathing for the last year they know
and even Alberto appreciates what I've
been doing lately I go I take the middle
one that I end with one that I stretch
he's like bro that's really good that
you're doing it from that perspective it
makes you come in here an extra week
what do I give a [__] you know you learn
how to work smarter when we've been
doing the podcast right we've learned
how to work smarter
that's what people do but by not doing
it you're not gonna have to learn to do
it correctly okay and these all go back
to fear
and that so I was telling this kid right
out I said
start with this competition sadly here
right here if something happens
you're here with us we got you
we put ice on your neck we get you a
[__] acai
and uh we sit with you so you don't feel
like that will help you breathe and he
kind of looked at me and he was like
maybe and I go if that works
then not even a mile away there's
another competition next month for blue
belts
blue belts that's it at vmac up the
corner if something happens to you it
will all be there it's a Sunday 11
o'clock I'm home that Sunday I'll be
there
how what you know what I'm saying so you
have to help people also you have to let
people know that
people also have to let people know
people who have anxiety like me are very
ashamed to tell people they have anxiety
I'm not ashamed especially if I'm with
somebody I've told the world we've
spoken about my anxiety on this [__]
show a thousand times before I go on
stage at the wool turn that was a short
period there I was really getting
[__] anxious like a [__]
and do you think it has to do like
something like how you like uh you you
like it by yourself you like being an
introvert because for me even
just the thought like even now when I
say like I've said a bunch of times I I
wish I had more friends I like to hang
out with people there's times
that I get very nervous just of the
thought of like because I'm so used to
being by myself and being and being
handling it by myself like the thought
of being around a lot of people like
that kind of freaks me out too I get it
I get it in 2001 I started booking
movies and [__] and I would get invited
to the screenings okay the staff and not
even the big screening with the Stars oh
the cast from the premieres the cast and
crew yeah I wouldn't get invited to the
premieres okay I did this movie called
American Gun with James Coburn
uh
I did another guy I did a few movies
that were just one scene two scenes
so I would never get invited to the
premiere okay was I upset no
I I just didn't like it but I learned
something from going to the cast and
crew ones I was getting just as much
anxiety at the cast and crew ones as I
was at this premieres
so I stopped going to the cast and crew
once
when I went so like I went to that I
remember that James Coburn movie they
[__] hated me really they got mad at
me for cocaine and drinking I was just
you know what man at that time I wasn't
even snorting and [__] you know it's
just amazing how you get blamed for
[__] everything they thought I had
gotten them booze or something
I was smoking dope on this set but it
was a it was a midnight set everybody
was smoking dope I was young I just got
in here I didn't know that monkey see
monkey do I saw people getting high I
started getting nine I got the blame
um you know what these [__] did
they cut me so bad from the movie they
just show my hand
giving the somebody the gun like that's
how much they got pissed at me but they
still invited me to the cast and crew
and just the anxiety of me sitting there
waiting for my role to come up ah was
brutal when I didn't see my face but I
heard my voice I was so [__] happy
most people would be upset because they
got cut I was so [__] happy because
yeah oh my God then there was something
else I did where I went with my wife we
did the whole day thing
it was at one of those [__]
director's places on Sunset the cheap
ones not even the real good ones it's
got It's called like Harmony Hut I don't
[__] know they scream little movies
they're 90 seats
I went the one there that this movie was
so [__] bad
I was ashamed to even be in the movie
but was more shameful was how the
[__] actors were acting this was a
[__] thing off Sunset nobody went to
see it there wasn't a person from the
industry that mattered in there these
people thought they were to cast a
[__] Glee Oh no they're hugging and
kissing I was so embarrassed but when my
role came up late I ran the [__] out of
that couldn't breathe that's the first
time I heard of that and I didn't say
nothing to nobody
okay and then
I did something else about a year later
and this one was like
like a medium big one and it was cast
and crew I thought it was the one with
David Spade I did and it was kind of
cast and crew and I went in there and
when my and my scene was in the
beginning
my scene for four or five movies do you
remember I wanted a role of the first
scene right you said taxi I think taxi
analyze that and that one with David
Spade I'm trying to remember which one
that was it's called I don't even
[__] know it don't matter
and uh
that movie when I went to see that one
with David Spade
I thought my head was going to blowingly
again I took my wife I thought my hat
was in the mall
and then there was a movie I did the
mezzo it was about two gay mobsters and
I was a gay mobster
and I took a bunch of people to see that
one and I ran out of the movie theater
now is it different for you like if
you're home by yourself is it that
there's people there it's even worse at
the house by myself
so I didn't know what it was people
would say to me though you were sitting
there and then you weren't and then you
were what happened I just went outside
to get there and they never really asked
me and I never really knew what it was
and then one day I was watching that
[__] crazy dude I'm running
and let him and ask them you know
Pirates of the Caribbean
Johnny Depp Johnny Depp and let him
asked him he goes so are you involved in
the
shooting process do you look at dailies
and he goes nope
he goes what do you mean you don't look
at them I don't watch dailies he goes
when the movie gets
uh cut the first edit do you watch he
goes no
he goes what about the premiere do you
go to the premiere goes yes but I run
out before my rolls come on he goes she
don't like he goes I can't stand
listening to my voice
and I can't stand watching myself it
gives me a weird feeling and that's the
feeling I get oh
the only movie I sat in the premiere
and kind of enjoyed because my friends
were there it was the longest yard for
me
but when I sat there with my wife I got
up
when I went to the cast and crew with
some friends from La I got up
the premiere in New York I sat with my
friends
high school and it felt good
I got up a few times and whenever I
would come up in the screen I would
whisper in a frenzy
throw it off oh okay I don't like that
none of that [__] either that [__]
creeps me the [__] out Jack so like I I
was just thinking like it's kind of nice
that almost I'm sure everyone even you
who seems to be so like uh confident all
that has anxiety and doubt but then I
was just thinking about like the people
who you who thought they were Glee do
you think they have doubt and anxiety or
are those kind of people just
they don't no they have no doubt they're
too worried about the glue
the gluten-free bread on the table and
how it's gonna
I think we all have some form of Doubt
or
uh
I mean I still haven't played 54 years
old
been doing comedy for 26 of those
[__] years
and I still go to a spot to haha and I
get nervous
I enjoy that nervousness
it's not
I mean come on man there's a thousand
people listening to this podcast I got a
tweet today from somebody who's gonna
get on stage I got a tweet yesterday
from somebody who's gonna go on stage
tomorrow night at Helium
for the first time
you know I love to do an interview do a
documentary and interview people who got
into comedy to tell me the truth how
long from the thought
Inception of getting on stage there's
some people are just great there's some
people who went to watch Lisa yet on a
talent night one of his employees and
they signed up and they got on stage but
there's people like me that from
the thought to when I got up on stage
two years
three years two and a half years from
the prison to the stage it was two and a
half years and then it was a couple
years to like full Do It full time he
said that it took me another four to
really get
to re it took me two
to get okay there you go it took me two
years to learn how to work smart it took
me two years to realize if I was going
to do this this is how it had to be done
it wasn't working by my standards
getting on stage once a week was not
gonna work
and thinking I was [__] Richard Pryor
that's not gonna work Joey
and that was my first thought I had so
many horrible thoughts like a lot of
other people have I had the thoughts
excuse me the thoughts of being
discovered
the thoughts of uh just going on stage
once a week and the thought of just
doing an hour because it was just
something you had to say and you were
that funny
all those thoughts that was the three
thoughts I had going into stand up and
I'm sure when you become
an underwater biologist or you become a
plumber or you become a [__] engineer
a structural engineer there's things you
thought about it
that okay we're going to talk about
somebody neutral my sister-in-law Paula
okay
Paula went to law school with thoughts
of
uh the DA's office there you go okay she
graduated and what happened
no day jobs why not they were [__] a
nightmare there's lists
thousands of applicants oh yeah
thousands so did Paula cave no you can't
no now this is what most people have
done
what okay you went to college you're an
intelligent dude
how many people want to go to college
get a D.A want to be a D.A they come out
Paula realized that after what 90 days
yeah Paul is not stupid she goes you
know what
this is gonna be tough I'm gonna have to
interview and interview again interview
again and it might not be a lie and I
guess you told me one time that it
wasn't for another two years yeah it's a
weird it's like a weird process
and then you and I were talking here one
day and we were talking about
immigration
the league just dropping on it she
speaks Spanish
you know yeah and sometimes what you
thought you were gonna do
is not what you thought you were gonna
do it's you're really doing it but not
just that field right I always thought I
was gonna be a stand though really I
never knew I was gonna be in a [__]
movie or a TV show I told you if I
thought that one day you would become
famous and go Joe you want to be an
extra in my movie sure I'll [__] hold
the [__] tomato
at a supermarket I don't give a [__]
because I thought I would only be an
extra now I'm acting with people
I've acted with well-known people okay
did anyone tell you to be an actor when
you moved here or did you do that when
you're on
the first manager I had said he was
gonna send me an audition I didn't know
what the [__] he was talking about yeah
I don't know what the [__] he was
talking about
he was like the uh we know you're a
feature act you only make 500 a week
that's fifty dollars if you go on the
road
okay for him fifty dollars for me I
can't keep the lights on
but he goes commercials are pain
now I never knew about commercials
that's how negligent I was to this whole
art game out here
I'd never even thought about commercials
even though you see them every day of
your life right who acts in those people
that was filming television so I thought
oh well you know I won't do any of those
and I came here in February January and
by the end of February I had the best
commercial agent at the time because
they all shift oh yeah approached me and
they called my manager and next thing I
commercial agent I'm like holy [__]
and if I sign with them on Thursday
I had a commercial that Monday it was
Popeye's Chicken oh I went over by
Sunset you know the big right two blocks
before Fairfax okay going west there's
an audition Studio there that's still
there that was my first commercial
Edition and I remember walking in there
and there being 60 people
in the back of my mind I'm like watch me
watch me watch my smoke
and me going up there reading the lines
thinking I was cool for this commercial
and I must have read whatever I went up
there and thought I was cocky and they
were like thank you for coming
and I called my commercial wage I did
great I'll be surprised if I don't book
I never heard dick oh no and the first
10 of them were all the same I went in
there thinking I was [__] Johnny
actor
and then I booked the real commercial
like three or four months in after you
learned how to do it
well the commercial has to be right for
you okay okay the commercial game the
theatrical game of two different [__]
games
let me give you an example okay when I
went for a mob role for a commercial I
always wear a white shirt
like a button-down shirt yeah like a
white shirt under the black suit okay or
the gray suit or the blue suit
when I go for a movie Mobster I wear a
black shirt or a blue shirt
you following me what's the difference
it makes me look a little nicer
and you don't want to look nice for TV
wanna look like a mobster for TV for
commercials you gotta look like a mops
but a little civilized
they want you to look like that but not
really ah okay
so you follow me I figured that out
because every time I wore a black shirt
to a commercial I didn't get it one day
I said let me switch it around I started
wearing right shirts some Mafia
commercials started getting
it added a different Patois that's funny
that you said that because I'm thinking
about it I think there's this one
commercial
uh it was like a
DraftKings commercial a year or two ago
where they like talk to your Uncle Bobby
yeah yeah I saw those guys every time I
see that I'm like why wasn't that Joey
because I'm looking at it he's a white
dude with red hair because I tell you
why okay because every time they make a
mob commercial
the Italian deformation League raises
their [__] ass oh no so all those
Mafia commercials you see that run they
always run for three weeks
so that's why like I'm On One commercial
they ran they complained and they said
we got a Cuban guy
we're not even attacking it so for that
they played it safe they just went with
a bunch of Irish guys right yeah or
Street looking guys and nobody got their
feelings hurt they ran the commercial
they whitened the commercials up for
white politics yeah especially two four
and fox okay and ABC 24 and ABC gotta be
by the book dog
Fox a little different FX you could
[__] blow your mother up and sell the
commercial for the [__] Band-Aid
the main three
I did not want to act when I came here
late it was the last thing I ever
thought I would do honestly even though
I was very impressed with actors and
there was a lot of actors that I grew up
to that I grew up
to kind of analyzing from Charles
Bronson to Clint Eastwood to download
Josie Wales just certain actors that I
just really enjoyed I never thought it
would work for me right when I came out
here they dropped the acting thing on me
and at first it was a little hard but
then I realized I live here
why am I not this is why you live here
is to be on TV and film right I don't
live here to go surfing I don't live
here to go to Venice Beach I don't live
here to go to Gold's Gym I don't live
here to walk around Melrose I live here
to do stand up and and now to act
and now to write
is it almost like like when you first
moved here you're still like looking for
spots and how you said Work Work Smart I
have this free time during the day might
as well audition it's like I was telling
you you know when I first got it even
though your pride doesn't want you to
get a job I got a job right because I
had a lot of obligations I had a Coke
addiction had a big child support you
know you know I was living in a [__]
car you have a lot of [__] you know
you know you can make money hustling
from doing comedy but what the [__] let
me get a guarantee let me make sure I
could bring home a nickel a week selling
cigars or a nickel a week selling screws
or a nickel a week it's time it's open
time what are you [__] uh Hemingway
what are you gonna write in five hours
your next Masterpiece go make money and
you can write this afternoon come home
at one sleep for two hours wake up at
three spots don't start till [__]
eight o'clock and they go till midnight
you can write till five
people have this [__] weird thing now
I'm gonna wake up in the morning and
right now you're not you're gonna smoke
a cigarette drink coffee smoke a joint
and talk to your buddies and you're
gonna throw stupid ideas on each other
why don't you go get a job cover the
[__] nut
so you're okay you walk around like a
human being
and then everything's good and trust me
even with the money I was making I was
still walking around wounded I couldn't
imagine not doing what I'm losing
[__] doing at the time when I got
that first commercial the first two or
three things there wasn't a dime that
went to me that all went to bills and
debts and [__] God knows what else
let me do some [__] shout outs here
real quick
Philip Rusty bazili you know I love you
[__] Robert pawley
Tony lucosto Garnett anachek Christopher
Jackson
Ray Quigley Larry Hartley Eric to Rob
to Robbie
talking lamb my man took care of me this
time in Vegas
and super Cherry I love you [__]
don't forget about me
anyway yes if there's any writers I've
read uh half of this book already The
Art of War for writers by James Scott
Bell fiction writing strategies tactics
and exercises I've read half of this
book already
and I'm blown away which means is I'm
going to read it again now with a little
[__] notebook next to me making notes
of this so listen so this is not the
same one as The Art of War no no no no
read books to that there's a couple
books to that oh okay people from the
show have sent me the whole collection
oh you know the Art of War for this this
is the one that Gordon sent me okay I
guarantee this is one of his clients and
uh it's James Scott Bell The Art of War
for writers if you wanna you know like I
said I got a lot of emails I got a lot
of Facebook messenger message and lately
I've been getting hit up from writing
like what's the best book what's the
best this
you know man there's 20 [__] good
books out there the one that got me
honest to God was
on writing by Stephen King but that was
me
there was one I read some years ago I
don't remember the ones I told you on
this if I bump into something that's
really really good I will run it through
you on the show I'm also reading a book
that Baba Lingus and his family sent me
the three lives of Jimmy Page
I'm [__] recorded through that this
book is as bigger than the Bible it's
bailing the [__] Bible so I'm three
quarters through that so
uh once I finished this so far what I'm
reading my dick is getting hard so so
far what I'm reading I like it so I'm
gonna try to look up that author and see
if I can have them call in and talk
about this this is a good book the three
lives of Jimmy Page I really try to read
guys especially on these [__] planes
you know what I bring a little notebook
on the planes I never read on the plane
I get one idea and one crazy idea I
tried on Thursday nights at each dick
and let me try it again like I can't
ride on planes when did you get into
reading
seventh grade really that early
let's go I'm lying to you when I went to
Catholic school there was one nun who
made you read a book and do like a book
report every see that's what killed it
for me and I would do like I did The
Godfather okay Mario Puzo I did the
Jonathan Livingston Siegel
for her I did uh I did four [__]
books for her like the Love Bug
she would make you read the book
describe the characters
and write what you thought of the plot
typed
three pages with a binder
sister analysis to Patricia
and that was when I learned a little bit
about books I thought it was a homework
assignment right yeah but then when I
went to Mr kingwell's class in the
seventh grade the first time
when you're still in the sixth grade the
last day of school in the sixth grade
before they moved you to the seventh
grade the next day okay
Mr King will come and said tonight guys
go read a book
go get a book
so he would give you a book to read for
the summer yeah and September one when
you came back you had to have a book
report on that book
from the summer
and the book I brought to him was Jaws
and the Jaws the first time but you had
to do one once a month Jack Jesus Christ
and you know what I just realized that
that's when I realized that if you're
not into something and you read it dump
it
dump it it's a horrible [__] read
dump it if it's in your world I don't
care if you tell me Joe I've read this
twice it's the best book I've ever read
it's like anything else
some movies I like you don't like some
movies you like I don't like you know
everything's not going to work for
everybody right
but I realized that you really got to be
into a book
to really [__] sink your teeth like
you know like I still know the books
that have I wish I could become that's
what my problem is that I'm a reader
and when you're a reader it's really
good for you
if you write or it can be really bad for
you because you try to compare yourself
to those [__] oh yeah but
there's no way there's books I've
written but I can write a [__] night
with a crayon that's so [__] bad
there's a ton of books I've read that
are terrible that have been done
overnight you could tell but there's a
lot of good books like [__] uh the
what's the uh what's the like the one of
the best books you know Cujo of course
and you know and the one about Ross
Perot and [__] like that but one of my
favorite [__] books ever
was the movie the one with the chick the
FBI agent Hannibal Lecter oh Silence of
lamb yeah it was one of the best books I
read have you read the series like the
red red dragon red dragon The Silence of
the Lambs and that's right and then I
read Hannibal no I'm lying to you I did
read animal I did read an animal before
the movie was released though
yes and I watched uh in fact Jeffrey
today
uh friend from the Twitter said in a
podcast listen hit me up and said he was
watching the whole Michael Mann
collection
which means he was watching Manhunter
okay uh Thief
and whatever he did like two or three
really good movies back to back look up
Michael Mann and IMDb and from uh 79 78
77 Michael Mann did some heavy [__]
[__] man
Jeffrey Collins hit me up today okay and
he has 21 Jesus all right but what was
he doing in 78
and 77. as a director right yeah 77
um
he did well his first movie was 81 was
Thief
yeah because he started out they needed
to keep
uh Manhunter was 83. wow La takedown uh
that's a TV movie The Last of the
Mohicans was 92 heat was 95. right
before those starts so he did so he did
a man Hunter and he's the thief and then
if you jump the television what comes up
for uh for him oh for Crime Story oh
yeah and Miami Vice
he didn't direct those I don't think
maybe he wrote them or something
they say anything on there let's see
here Miami Vice all Crime Story
police story is that story he did police
story from 76 to 78. yep Starsky and
hunch he wrote four episodes what else
um
he wrote the screenplay for thief
oh yeah Miami Vice in 85
he wrote uh one episode
and then the screenplay for Manhunter
Crime Story and crime story he
Ali he wrote this later
drug wars the camera story yeah and The
Last of the Mohicans
that's crazy they keep
Vegas he did 68 episodes
I don't know what that is that's 78.
and then he did that uh that horse show
on HBO but it really you know that's
irrelevant it's just so weird how I
liked I I enjoy reading me and I fly man
and you can listen to an iPod for so
long right and you can [__] read a
movie for someone you know go watch a
movie I gotta tell you something those
books add up
those books add up I had to start
reading them and I said [__] it when I
get on the plane I know I'm not going to
be bothered I got about a good hour and
a half read you know how much I could
read in an hour and a half a lot
you know and then you take a little
breather then you listen to music
then if you listen to music for an hour
and then you watch the TV and Bam there
you are what is it like reading hi I've
never read anything even better I can't
I would imagine even better your
imagination your glasses on you get a
little [__] diet soda you put your
feet up you take good care of yourself
and you read and you take your mind
somewhere else instead of both but I
learned Lee
that I wish I would have done when I was
28 was learn how to take my mind out of
the [__] yeah how do you do that
because that's what kills us
that's what kills you as a human being
when you let
your everyday struggles go home with you
at night and you absorb them
and they bring into different moods and
they leave you the drinking or whatever
but that's not the whole thing
just that stress and that worry
upon your brain and your mental state
and your central nervous system it's not
good for you you know and I could how
the [__] do you know Joey what the [__]
after my mother died
that little thing I had of constantly
thinking about my life and what was
going to happen it was wearing me out
man
it was worrying me out
and whenever I've had those issues I
could feel it that's what kills you yeah
people say people have heart attacks
from stress what the [__] is stress
you know it's funny what uh
our friend was saying last night that he
has to work three weeks a month to make
the rent you know and it's like the guy
said in [__] uh Fight Club you can't
let the things you owned
on you
when you start letting the things you
own on you
that stress
that's when you can't sleep at night how
am I gonna make that car payment how am
I gonna make that High School payment
um I gotta pay for vacation how am I
gonna do this you know
this [__] will kill you more than all
those subjects combined if you really
think about it
because there's no doubt as prison
and I don't care how many binds you
build in your life you always seem to
work yourself out
you really do as an individual you
really do nobody's better than anybody
else nobody's special on anybody else
everybody in their life
gets put into two or three dark
situations and you know what man you
always work yourself it's like the man
said you don't get what you want
but you get with your [__]
[__] need though that's so
frustrating it's it's frustrating I I
don't know maybe it's just me but as a
kid growing up even to like I think
that's what I'm struggling with now is
like you grow up and you
I just think there's an end point
there's like okay you get to a certain
point of success and then you can enjoy
everything and and relax and everything
that I'm hearing and figuring out is
That Never Comes That Never Comes at all
so it like that it's it's very
frustrating if you don't
you shouldn't it's not frustrating
because again you're putting your head
somewhere where it should not be
whatsoever okay
it should not be whatsoever you know you
know you're a good guy and I'll tell you
what I'll I'll [__] blow you out of
the water and this is not to be funny or
to be cute
is just to tell you where my head was at
1984 which makes me 21 years old I went
to the doctor because of blood coming
out of my stool
it had been coming out of my stool for
about three months do you know why
people
because I would go to sleep worried
I'd wake up at three in the morning
worried
and I go back to sleep worry
I got the beginnings of an ulcer
he put me on that yellow medication and
they gave me like low end whatever and
but the doctor kept telling me to come
in and talk with him and he was an old
dude with white hair
and he was right there it's like okay
and he I don't know what his name is now
guys I don't remember where his office
was it was Snowmass Village 1983.
it was the summer of 83 I was 21 years
old
I had no family
I had a bank account with maybe 82
dollars into the sun
I live in a two-bedroom apartment and
I was taking three credits a semester
maybe six at a at Colorado Mountain
College
and think about it I
had no [__] idea
I had no idea I had nobody I could call
and say hey
I can't pay rent I need six of those
there was nobody I had to make this
every [__] month
and I would sit there every month and
sweat the month out
and then sweat the quarter out you know
even though I had a job even though I
had a good way to get to that job every
day there was no excuse like it wasn't
like I don't have a car I had to wait
there was a way there was a bus that
took me right in front of the place I
didn't have to walk a foot it would drop
me off and I had to cross the street
I had a job I had a place to stay at
that time I was robbing a little bit I
had a little put away
but I was playing with fire that's a
complete different story but all that
thought I was wasting at night
I understood thinking back now I
understand 40 of that thought
it's natural but I was driving myself
crazy
I was beating myself up
and it was just too much for that age
and you know what that doctor those six
weeks I talked to him once a week
the blood went away
and I never put myself there again I
still thought
but I never sweated it out like I used
to
till this day you asked me things and
I'll tell you I'm not sweating them I
don't worry about it
there's nothing to worry about
it's going to either work your way or
not
and if it doesn't you'll figure out a
way to make your world that's it that's
all [__] life is there's a few
curveballs from time to time the big
thing listen what's a fighter a fighter
isn't somebody who could throw great
punches or great kicks
or take Jiu Jitsu really good it's
somebody who could take a [__] Punch
To The Head
three times when people go oh
and come back and knock a [__]
out and win with his bone sticking out
of his ear oh my God that's a that's a
fighter with that Gadget guy whoever
yeah that's what we are and when people
realize that see that's what you've
never focused on
you focused on that that does not never
stop listen you're 28 years old all
you're going to focus on and get the
next next Thursday is your birthday
you'll be 29 years old all I want you to
focus on is 29 years old
I want you to focus on
the 30th day the 90 day
and the 120. what did I say if you need
to get a notebook that's what you start
next Thursday
and every week
and dog I write everything if I'm angry
about something now I take the notebook
I open it up and I write the whole story
out and then I read it and I go what the
[__] am I mad about I wish I would have
known this
when I was 29 years old
I wish I would have known these things
that there's no payoff and worry
all I want you to do is do
think about how you're gonna do it and
do it don't think about nothing else if
you think today that kid I tell you from
Jiu Jitsu We Roll today right we rolled
for a reason because I saw I learned
something from him from watching him
today okay that's why I told you it all
starts with the mental
you
you do a warm-up
you learn the technique you drill the
technique you get water and then you
call breaking the guard where you get in
my garden all you have to do is pass it
if you pass my guard you get on your
back and somebody has to pass your guard
if you sweep them you stand your back
okay they do that for 15 minutes at
every class
so I was watching it today
and this kid has gotten so good
that in his mind
before you even click hands with him and
he grabs your ghee
he decides
that you're not gonna pass this guy
it's amazing to watch his face on what
happens he just decides he just decides
that's why I explained to him today that
he had to compete
because he's that good I watched a guy
30 pounds heavier than him
almost pass his guard and this kid
opened up and held onto his ghee and
with his gee flipped over into the
turtle position and then grabbed the
guy's legs and took him down
in his mind so if in his mind
he could decide
that somebody's not gonna pass his guard
and his mind he could go to a
competition and overcome this little
anxiety he gets like I told him you
can't go to the worlds first
you're gonna cave if you go to the
world's first that's like if I go to
Vegas next August and try to compete in
the world for the first competition I'm
gonna cave and I'll probably quit
jiu-jitsu all I Ronda Rousey you just
quit you get such a beating that you
just quit and it's a shame that's what
happens
I moved a little too fast
I would do competitions at Cranes I
would just go give me three blue belts
I'll give you 50 bucks a piece
you know and I would start with five
minute rounds from A to Z the takedown
and I guarantee I would lose all three
fights okay I don't have a chance in
hell
I mean I'm telling you this because my
breathing
I couldn't fight three times five minute
rounds seriously Speedy like that unless
I lean on you and even then
it's not gonna [__] work
okay but
I would to overcome that little bit of
fear
but I have I'm not prepared yet he is
but I looked at him today and I go if
you decided
that people aren't going to pass your
guard
you could decide to control the anxiety
like when I was wrestling in my home I
have to stop for a second I can't slow
down my breathing
I've extended my time rolling but I
still can't control my breathing when my
heart beats like that I can't slow it
down and that's what gives me the
anxiety I've control the anxiety now I
just have to sit there for a minute
longer and breathe it out and just focus
on my breathing and
has the time uh so like when you start
when you're rolling and you start
getting anxiety from that point to the
point where you have to stop has that
point gotten longer now
to heavy are you are you able to deal
with the fear what it's doing is it's
percentages okay that's what I'm trying
to say so
I went from getting anxiety a hundred
times 100 till now I have anxiety 50
okay because the more I go the more the
anxiety will go down gotcha if I don't
go if I take gaps in between my mind
will let the anxiety grow so I can never
let that happen before it grows I go
down that bubble like today I was sore
from yesterday but [__] it boom and I'll
go again tomorrow before you know I'll
go again tomorrow because I don't want
the fear to grow
by the time the fear shows up I'm
already on the mat and I've already over
company you follow me that's what I was
doing the same thing with stand up when
I got into stand up I would get on stage
once a week and die and then walk around
like I was Joey bananas like oh I did
great no you didn't no you didn't then I
would go down there next week and die
again even though I was getting on stage
once a week okay I had to change up the
seriousness of my game
and and then that goes back to what we
were talking about the beginning of
being prepared
and commitment right okay
commitment is cousins with preparation
it is yeah totally commitment is cousins
with preparation all this game is
cousins you have to look at cousins it's
all the same so commitment and
preparation they're all [__] Cousins
but preparation commitment in your mind
like I saw my friend do today when I
looked at his face that kid was past his
garden he flipped backwards he had no
reason to he could have hurt himself
he could have hurt his back and been out
for six weeks he don't know that
but he decided this kid wasn't gonna
pass this guard just because of who he
is
and that
is what beats anxiety
belief in your mind you know how I know
I'm living it
you know how many times I've gone to an
audition walked in there
signed my name looked around and seen
people that I've seen in Big Time movies
and I've sat down the corner and I go oh
[__] I'm not gonna get that well I just
lost a war
I could tell you six rolls I lost
because of that because I got
intimidated by who was there one time I
tell you intimidate the [__] out of me
Joe bonafuco until I left and I go why
did I just throw that audition Joe
bonafuco cannot act me and he can't
[__] out comic me
and it wasn't a big deal it was some
[__] disaster of a game show or a
reality show so just that one thought it
totally took you out of it well and that
happens for everything
that train of thought will happen for
[__] will take you out of the game it
did me for years and once I started like
I was telling Paul the other day before
the [__] thing went South before the
train went South I was telling Paulie
sure that in my mind
and I and I say this and a lot of people
are not going to agree with me and
they're gonna get mad at me or disagree
I'm telling you people because I don't
[__] you [__] I'm telling
you that in my mind
the training I got from The Comedy Store
as a comic which is a training nobody
could give you it's a club on the Sunset
Strip you're on stage with celebrities
and stars when you first come out here
that's a weird [__] world but
navigating through that training
made me
uh
a Green Beret of Comedy I always felt
that The Comedy Store comics
were always Green Beret of County what
does that mean well not your
[__] first choice
you call us when [__] goes south and we
show up and they drop us out of a
helicopter with a knife in our mouth and
two [__] fins in the school bar on
our back that's how I've always felt
about the comments but joy what would
you say a dumb statement like that why
because I saw it I saw people go in
there that were mediocre comics
become tremendous [__] Comics i.e.r.e
should fear I.E Joe Rogan I.E Freddie
Soto rest in peace the lisco crystalia I
saw a lot of comics that walked into the
comedy store many yoga comics and Midway
two three years somewhere it snaps and
now you know your [__] mission
okay The Improv has their own style of
Comedy you've been to all three clubs
right whether with Paula with me and
everywhere has their own style of comics
but the solid homies
I'm telling you that the comedy storm in
my mind after like three or four years
at The Comedy Store the beat now was
taken there on a daily night again it's
percentages
uh Seinfeld said this and the Judy
Carter book The more you get on stage
it's all percentages the more I go to
Jujitsu the fear will go down because
it's all percentages when you get on
stage as a comic first 10 times you're
gonna bomb second ten times you're gonna
do nine you're gonna bomb nine out of
ten
the third time you're gonna do eight out
of ten and so on and so on until your
percentages is forty percent thirty
percent of Bobby
I still bomb today 26 years of Comedy
I still bomb
and when I bomb I love it because that
means I got out of the way and here I
come [__] I got another 90 days
because the percentages get lower and
lower I'm more prepared when I go on
stage now
even if I get myself into a dark place I
could navigate myself out of there
and that's all based on this working
commitment what is six years yeah 26
commitment elimination of fear 26
[__] years
that I've been putting bad predicaments
in all you know when you're a roofer or
an electrician a plumber uh
all those trades and I can you do new
construction like there's people who do
new construction
and there's people who do uh what's on
the construction like they come in the
remodels gotcha okay those guys do
remodeling construction those guys are
great
when you do a remote it comes out great
and they come in and out of bathroom or
whatever all those things are difficult
guys
the reason why you're paying them is
your expertise
of
finding problems and overcoming those
problems
right like for example you'll come to me
and go on this weekend I bought a house
Joey I'm redoing the downstairs bathroom
I'll say you're using the plumber and
you'll go no no no no no I wanna I went
online and yeah
and this dude set the bias cassette and
do it also Midwife during your Thailand
right yeah I don't know what you're
doing now you have to call the plumber
and you have to pay him to do what you
define if you do the paid diploma
those people those type of people come
in new construction you build
I tell you to come in and build this
wall 12 by 14 all the same that's what
you do build me 22 of those 22
Apartments that's what you do
with Remodeling and Roofing like my
brother-in-laws
they were [__] geniusesly
every time I went on a roof with those
guys I learned something
like I was saying that everybody would
say listen if you work with those two
dudes watch them and listen to what they
say it's the small details of their job
that relate with flashing flashing means
when you run into piping and air
conditioners on a roof if you don't do
those right they leak and it causes a
tremendous problem
when you worked with these guys this
[__] never leaked because they did it
and redid it and redid it they did that
extra time that people don't do to get
it out of the way
but they faced any like when I worked
with them I always learned something
and other roofers would come up and go
Jesus Christ
these [__] guys are geniuses
they were professionals they knew how to
overcome obstacles
right the more you do something you you
learn how to overcome obstacles one guy
I gotta hand it to in the stand-up world
there's one person that now I think
about it and I got to tell you who's
[__] great he used to put himself in
dark Corners all the time the reason why
Joe Rogan's a great comic
it because he used to put himself in
dark corners
either by following strong people or
saying something on purpose to trying to
get somebody's attention to work himself
out of a hole that genius move
at a young stage in his career made him
the comment he is today
he threw his own obstacles of himself
which I did we all do as comedians for a
while because
we want to try
laughs
that's a tremendous [__] fight right
there people I had a little salad oh my
God a little protein shake that's what
that sounds like a [__] Fourth of July
leftover that sounds like somebody
popped the ball of champagne on the
fourth of [__] July tremendously
oh my God it was so clear it was
tremendous it was I didn't think even
that people was going to be heard but
hey I'm sorry things happen all right if
you don't fart [__] you
he who live in a glass house draw the
first stone oh I'm always gonna let me
ask you this because it sounds like you
never get like that relaxing time our
farts still funny at 54. like you still
gonna have a good time when people fart
in my world yeah hilarious all right
good for me not for everybody else oh
yeah well for me at 54 yeah if I'm
sitting there at night watching TV and
the two cats are next to me and I blow a
fart and they both look at me weird and
I look at them like who the [__] is
running things you know what I'm saying
and one of them always jump off there's
one cat that'll go something ain't right
here do you like angled at them if
they're sitting there well if my ass is
pointed that way and those two are
looking at me
well a lot of people might just point it
backwards or into the couch listen down
the couch that's a privilege they won't
be on that this is what they're gonna
have to deal with my feet and my [__]
[__] you don't like it go back to the
ASPCA and let them lock you up and
[__] some of the homo finds you like
me I'm the only [__] home one that's
got six cats because I fell in love with
them let some other today I was sitting
in the kitchen and I'm making that
[__] protein shake before I go to
karate the the Jujitsu the [__]
little water so I could drink it at
Jiu Jitsu and gray comes in the black
and white one the the last one I got
I adopted her over there at [__] up
the corner from the office here
and I used to play with her every day
and then the the lady downstairs the cat
got attacked one night like one night I
didn't see like this went on for like a
year her and I had this little romance
when I leave to do comedy I'd see gray
and when I come back gray would be
waiting for me or I would go great
and she would come running from wherever
she was and I had treats her at the top
of the stairs
and she'd walk up to the top of the
stairs with me and I give him the treats
and I'd pet her for 15-20 minutes
and I'd go inside with my other cats and
then at night in the morning I'd come
out and there she was right there
right there to hang with me and the
other cats were the hissing her and [__]
and I loved them and I remember one day
she disappeared for a while
and I was concerned like I kept asking
my wife but you've seen [__] gray
[__] come on let's get in the car and I
saw a grade two blocks away and they go
Gregory and the only way we could get a
home is if I got out of the car
and she followed me home
and the owner of the house was like I've
had this cat for [__] six years this
cat don't like nobody this is [__]
crazy
so when she got attacked by the skunk or
whatever attack that she had around with
the hospital with the infection no she
couldn't live back outside again
so she came to me she goes I'm either
going to put her in the pound or give
her away do you want she loves you and I
go no I'm taking it and I took Grant and
that was how long and I'm looking at it
she's gained 10 pounds she's clean
she's happy I saw her kissing Demi
yesterday
I saw her next to me and I saw Demi walk
up to me in the office
and they looked at each other but they
both kissed each other she likes Demi
she likes Harry she don't like super bad
she's constantly attacking super bad she
stays away from the girls she don't [__]
with the girls they have a lot more
rooms to like a Ted attack each other
into the new house yeah but she's on the
couch constantly but it was so weird how
that little animal in me like I was
sitting there looking around sitting
there making a drink I shook it up
I put the drink down I had no food to
give her another it's like she was there
begging no no no just came up to me and
said what's going on I just woke up
yeah I'm gonna take a little stretch I
wanted to say hello
I picked her up and it's so weird when
should I pick her up and I put her in my
chest
it's a little ahead
on my shoulder like she's thank you and
I better she gives me about six minutes
and then she'll make a little meow that
means all right enough is enough [__]
sucker I almost much love from you and I
lead let it go down she leaves and then
I won't see it till night time and I I
could be wrong but didn't she get out a
couple years ago and like Escape like
get lost from a while
she went into the garage and they locked
her in there oh no and I was [__]
cracked listen yeah I was cracked I
couldn't sleep at night and [__] I was
ready to call the police I was [__]
cracked
and I uh they opened up the garage one
day and there she was
just
sitting there she ran in the house and
she'd never left again she don't walk
out that door she looks outside from
time to time she goes yeah it's nice out
there tonight but [__] it this is good
in here I got a cot
I watch TV now I got a little [__]
toys I'm playing with because I play
with them at night when I go home that's
how I am one
just a little cat yeah cause mom is in
bed the baby's in bed and the cats are
out one by one and once I get home the
later I get home the more of them will
be out like I'll get home now and this
morning
and they'll play with me for a little
while the later you get home they'll be
two
you know what I'm saying you get home
like at midnight it's like to react and
then from the energy you send out from
playing with those three cats the other
ones come to life and they come into the
living room they gotta play with all
them they gotta take a brush while
you're there
see and cats are good because dogs bark
yeah no no these guys just purr and
you're petting them it's like one in the
morning and you can feel the [__]
energy in the room you're brushing them
brushing them
and the next thing you know [__]
one of them will swap one of them and
[__] so then they'll be down to four of
them and now I have four of my super bad
Harry
Demi and maybe Gray
and I'll be brushing that you know and
that'll be what's left then something'll
happen with Demi and Harry it's such a
weird combination but now since I
scratched their back they have those
different pheromones what do you call
them animals on their back now they're
awake
and now it sets that it's really weird
unless you have a [__] cat I'm sorry
I'm talking about [__] cats people I
just haven't talked about the cats in a
long time I want we were talking about
fears and [__] like that listen anyway
I'm gonna be in St Louis Thursday Friday
and Saturday night and then like I said
July 29th we'll be at the Borgata
um that's it and that's that I'm really
sorry this weekend about the guest when
all this [__] happened you know and I
couldn't recover but let me tell you
something next week we got a tremendous
week for you [__] I'm happy
that uh you guys still support us and
you're still not going to we're here you
know what this is the Church of what's
happening my [__] we're here
before we leave though let me talk to
you [__] about something all
right that's important to me listen man
you know there's a lot of things going
on right now uh
you know maybe you're looking for a job
maybe I don't know I don't know what the
situation is in your life but listen you
can never have more uh enough money Lyft
knows that their drivers are what keeps
them moving so they do everything they
can to make sure that drivers are happy
on every trip
it's a simple formula happy drivers
means happy passengers right you get in
the car the dude's in a good mood he's
talking to you you tell him open up the
back window blah blah blah blah that's
why that's why nine of the 10 Lyft rides
get a perfect five-star rating you can
earn hundreds of dollars a week plus
tips you want to earn more money right
the holidays are coming believe it or
not it's July but the holidays are
coming you you drive more if you want to
earn more money you drive more if we
don't want to make money that week you
take a few days off it's never been
easier to give yourself a raise Lyft was
the first ride share platform with
tipping built right into the app because
getting tip shouldn't depend on your
passion you're having a crumble bill in
their pocket you keep 100 of the tips
and let me tell you something they add
up fast drivers have been paying over
200 million dollars since the feature
was first introduced and express pay
lets you get paid almost instantly
instead of waiting for weeks Lyft is has
even taken the guesswork out of pickups
the new amp device uses color coding to
help passengers find their drivers so do
yourself a favor join the ride sharing
company that believes in treating their
people better go to lyft.com right now
slash Joey today and get a 500 new
driver bonus that's lyft.com Joey again
lyft.com Joey get yourself a little job
and a five and a little new driver bonus
limited time only terms apply let me ask
you something
times are tough you got a business are
you hiring do you know where to post
your job to find the best candidate no
you don't let me ask you something like
I told you earlier in the podcast you
know how it is to find somebody
Dependable I hit the home run with Lee
I had a home run really you know I'll
find this to find somebody Dependable
somebody would take showers some of you
you can trust somebody who's educated
you know how important it is to run a
successful business okay with zip
recruiter you can post your jobs to a
hundred plus job sites with one click
bam then their powerful technology
efficiently matches the right people to
your job better than anybody else that's
why zip recruiter is different unlike
other job sites zip recruiter doesn't
depend on candidates finding you
it finds them in fact eighty percent of
jobs posted on zip recruiter get a
qualified candidate in just 24 hours no
juggling emails no calls to your office
simply screen rate manager in one place
with zip recruiters easy to use
dashboard find out today why
ZipRecruiter has been used by businesses
of all sizes to find the most qualified
job candidates with immediate results
and right now today
our family our listeners can post jobs
on ZipRecruiter for free Gratis that's
right free just go to ZipRecruiter
church it's that easy that zipper crew
this last church supercooter.com
ziprecruiter.com church it's that easy
ziprecruiter.com church one more time
try for free go to ziprecruiter.com
church again I want to thank zip
recruiter I want to thank Lyft I want to
thank uh on it and I want to thank most
importantly you guys I love you guys
with all my [__] heart without you I
got a lots all right I'll see you guys
Monday ready to rock if not I'll see you
Thursday night in St Louis get ready to
light your wig on fire we're going deep
into the murky Waters I love you guys oh
by the way again The Art of War for
writers James Scott Bell thank you again
for listening have a great weekend
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you